hey everybody welcome back to another
week of top 5 scary modes of the week
and cam this is said we're both wearing
blue why is that cerb well today's you
know international scotland day yes
maybe it I thought you hide from your
dress up in your national colors do you
think you know why we're still part of
the UK and all oh it's gonna have we're
gonna stay we're gonna see you yeah
trust me yeah trust me it's gonna happen
mmm that means we can still be friends
yes cuz I was getting all ready to hate
you what you're gonna have independence
from me never well that's my cue
I thought that's buddy go no friends in
Scotland Wow okay well until that time
let's make the most of this episode of
scaring Marsden Seb and get on with more
number one okay sir but everyone else
walking to mod number one which this
week's episode of a mouthful it's the
way of the dovahkiin ultimate deadly
encounters aka sands of time they said
this mod is fantastic I think because it
adds in all those kind of tropes and
things from traditional RPG and also
with Dungeons & Dragons s games yeah
when it comes to encounters so for
example just wandering the wilds of
Skyrim you can have more random
encounters we're not just there also if
you sleep you can get interruptive in
the counter if you fast travel you can
get interrupted an encounter yeah
pretty much anything you do you can be
interrupted with an encounter and the
game will let you know what's happening
try also you covertly advance what is
that really covertly advancing on or
what is why there's potentially friends
maybe maybe pain maybe gifts oh dragger
attacks a drag or a toga ah guys come
from it just came from there
reinforcements wow we're really getting
hit hard okay pretty serious encounter
oh there's a lot of triger how many
reinforcements did he
it stable confessed we did put this on
there nightmare mode yeah those numbers
different like inbuilt difficulty levels
enemy cancers is increase oh man it
looks like they're just gonna keep on
going drone over we go to 40 chickens Oh
God
take that dragger we're just minding
your business and for a beautiful wintry
stroll wet olan rubbish a minute Erica
are you son of a [ __ ] hunt I'll get it
I'll get it
ah you hey buddy you can feed us sorry
oh I missed him I showed this mod out oh
wait hey rabbit evolved chat done this
way Oh draw our attack bandit attack now
get your goddamn bandits wonder if
they'll fight each other oh they are
lovely they are fighting each other I
think the drugs got this BAM
so the thing is right the sands of time
MCM menu may be the most epic I see a
menu of it Jean and each one of these
goes on some way as well all we did was
ultra presets we came down here quick
preset yeah got nightmare hurt me
Spartan ale drinker at milk drinking
let's go for Spartan that I think that's
probably safe or otherwise we're never
gonna move anywhere we should constantly
encountered yeah
off with your head this feels like a
more very very much suited to Kevin it's
like is this more death more dealing or
killing I can do that dispatching
bandits maybe the thing that Kevin is
best at as well as we can see here oh
you get on that table and then I sliced
your throat in fact he's a tiny infected
rat how you contracted the bubonic
plague right we're gonna sleep next to
these dead wolves do it let's go damn
rat don't judge us alright we're very
tired
Kevin huh she does sleep better with
something to cuddle in other news Kevin
is never oh you hear something what's
happening
nice sleeping what ah found it Marauder
get hours lately Vic oh wow they were
all drowsy ah what's going on leave me
I'm so sleepy but I can still see the
kill you oh god it's a danger isn't the
moon beautiful another bandit never
should have come here I was sleeping
here you should never have come here
others two of them wow that's like me on
most mornings no your dad dad you wake
me up there are random healers now
around in the various Inns and taverns
around of Skyrim and this one is it
Melanie so let's see what Melly can do
heal my disease ease great all diseases
cure your voices neutralized we were
poisoned oh yeah remember we had that
awful
bubonic coupon ik plague and babish in
our own room Oh God hey it's bandit I
think we just need to connect with our
arm again there we go reconnected Oh
least the healers help us thanks healer
I love how you go sleeps with a turret
don't you now we've killed a whole lot
of innocence in this bar now said if you
do what we just done and kill a bunch of
innocence you can come across this boss
character the burning Inferno who's
meant to basically and I believe he'd
give us some revenge yeah she defends
the innocence she can take a hit from
Kevin Bernard boy someday I'd
rush the only way to kill her is to
remove part of an edge all right well
that is basically the tip of the iceberg
on what there is for sands of time
there's light there's armored stuff
there's all the spawning things that you
can change there's weapons reinforcement
changes you can make basically there's
tons and tons and tons to this mod so
we'll let you guys explore it for the
rest until then I think we should
probably crack on with mod number two
coup okay Serb time for mod number two
and this week that's Sofia the funny
fully voiced following funny and fully
dad we are spoiled it's been a while
since we've had a follower um and
they're all there she is right there
I think sleep is seeing this is having a
cool these stables of Whiterun let's go
in there and talk to her it's fear yes
I'm listening I mean what no I've never
seen you before I have no idea who you
are what we came about no like I've been
stalking you or anything
aren't you going to flex your muscles
and tell me how great you are we both
know that where it seems to be the
customary greeting in Skyrim that's how
we greet here in England what have your
clothes what I have no idea it's like
you've never seen it semi naked woman
before hold on we only did the Wonder
Woman load a few weeks ago we are
familiar
well that course is gonna do her no good
in a battle unless so much ice to attack
her shoulders in which case should be
quiet the CH doesn't come back oh wow
loads of them oh pretty decent Oh
horsies getting involved get in there
horsey so shooting those spells as well
I think so yeah come yes she is fire
spells man
she's pretty good that bandit was real
tough hey where are you is melody good
are we get okay we do we kill we
definitely cool hey also better check
I'm wearing underwear what
I think she's flirting with us said
hello the horse is like what have I done
no no I had you know I had no choice you
saw I saw it you all saw it yeah
nothing settles the spirit like spirits
after a good fight I think the bannard
mayor you know better man oh she's
drinking already
what can I get you look more booze
please okay okay you look a bit boost
yeah I feel like I'm being stared at
what
she's definitely I can't help I'm
beautiful hey try again what's on your a
mine yeah I could use another what I
already gave you all my drink down we're
building wind the big ugly beast once
sing off sing up break it down when
drunk said she can still start a fight
yeah she show again he's got here drunky
oh yeah look at her stagger
hurry up when you come up here no I'm
time for this
ah this is why Kevin never does this why
is her cheese in room
hurry up hurry up all right I'll forget
her forget her sad that's it
Dovahkiin where did that system from
your clothes what the black sheep ain't
givin ya address Jer do you like you
have more booze no because you lose well
you just don't wear the clothes that I
give you our SAP time for mod number
four which is simply called misty castle
mod mmm now we are on the plains next to
Whiterun there's white run out of focus
in the background if we pan the camera
riders and there it is yes castle in the
sky look at that that's really awesome
that's very studio ghibli so I do
believe that we've got to run into this
this hip Hillier at the bottom oh no
chances up to the misty Castle I don't
know about you cam that this kind of
reminds me of another place in Skyrim
this misty Castle is very similar to
solitude in there solitaire with these
fancy glowing lowering lamps so here's
why do speak out you know air cows back
house space cows it's this case first
zebra cat yeah
snowball he seems nice no more no
appears to be following us amazing so I
believe what we're looking for is a
crazy old man who's your man yes yeah
what's the matter hole bogey bring me a
stone and I'm done with lord wants him
for all okay I guess you follow this guy
I'm the key to the town
I bet that is the temple but I guess we
have to find key we had a quest marker
added it's sitting on nothing that's
because he's crazy cam sure so cross the
bridge was the lair
oh we can actually go in here nice ah
hello yeah maidservant hi
you forced me to do something I have to
walk on the table sorry sorry out oops
oops oops who's this guy
uh-huh it's not neat iron throne what
watch this guy one of swords yes nice
see something I love her something I
shall only sit in there you got any
spare swords ah
and the girls quarters no less nailed it
in this lockbox now there we get key for
the lord's tomb and a crapload of gold
let's go we didn't even get caught nope
said we finally made it into the temple
in the misty castle yeah feels like a a
that torch is very uneffective on that
wall yeah I know and yeah we don't do a
lot of quests at the moment see it's
nice to see that this one apart from
just being a giant floating city has a
room with a lot of doors loli to the
full of patience Oh weird maze thing Oh
what have we done what have we done
I don't know the whole of patience I
think I have an idea of what we're
having for begin users have been totally
taking track of every door good not I'm
having memories of a particular tower in
Game of Thrones yes yeah I wonder if
maybe you supposed to use the wall
sconces to tell you which one that
you've been in as in like every door you
go through you take away a torch taking
them all or just teeth
if we take him all of my unlocker thing
or not
sir bleep really be traps in the hole
efficiency I believe we are not patient
enough for the whole operation Devin's
not known for his patience
uh let's patiently move on to mod number
four okay time for mod number four which
is cheese fi shouts people into cheese I
think I think I see where this is going
good I feel I should activate this goat
cheese with yeah so this is a Geograph
can't grants you the cheese if I shout
sugar oath has got all the best so this
is this is just the the cheese it is in
that's always there and Whiterun yeah
dairy cheddar cheese nice nice all right
so let's hear it sounds Oh Ashley you
throw a cheese wheel let's try this guy
oh that works quick defend yourself yeah
there you go
everything is it's not a reliable or
consistent cheese either Wow he's got
quite a wide berth yeah very area bikes
I missed child charger she's doing out
uh well she just catches it and throws
it on the floor I just know everything
auntie but once you've turned someone to
cheese they can never be unturned prawn
cheese so uh this has the power to be a
very game breaking mod oh he lays Nancy
the healer is there nursing duties heal
me Matt's a witch what which teas would
serious cheat I'm so sorry
no it's not just a goat's cheese wheels
just just wheel raisin and not only that
but you see out of yourself a bounty by
picking her up
Wow I pro cash cow cheese the most dairy
of all of the changes there you go
all right I feel like we need to up the
ante of this cheese oh Jesus sorry did I
say Jesus very good I said we all know
malice like cheese there it's that
favorite thing
oh it's amazing oh it's perfect
quick
haha they stood no chance ah three
wolves wolves at all but now that she
was mentally hacks oh I think they all
want to be cheese I think they do
ah close their disdain of choices known
quick come on - yes - yes I got one it's
really cheese you got - I get both of
them I can do a - yes huh what a shove
is here it's like duck hunting but with
cheese and Dragons instead of pretty
much entirely the same your son ha ha ha
oh wow got them all already yeah I think
you did well
Wow I think I've got a few right of the
beginning and I spammed it this is a
world that I've dreamed of I think we've
we've stumbled upon possibly the
greatest hunting activity ever is this
is this gonna be a keeper is this
shooting giant shooting dragons with
cheese it's just wonderful
okay everyone time for a final mod of
today which is the strange vault and Seb
I see your apparel yeah but not just a
pair of boots this is a portkey of
course famously from Harry Potter
Porky's when touched will transport you
somewhere very specific and the
Bellatrix Lestrange vault had a very
very powerful defense mechanism I see if
this is the same well yeah that's the
teleporting boot ever so on so this does
look very much like her vault so hers
had more cheese in the film what
happened was first on Harry summoned a
load of cheese
yeah and Hermione said no Harry less
please we're here for something very
specific and he said shut up
he says shut up this cheese shut up this
is it's not called Hermione and the
Goblet of cheese when they touch
something that isn't specifically what
they're looking for it begins to
replicate everything so if you start by
touching on those gold ingots
it's a replicates itself as you keep
touching things in here
they're gonna start filling up and not
just the gold ingots but everything in
here as well I always wanted more girls
Oh God uh yep so we go this is what
happens wading through through stuff I
don't understand if this is maybe the
best place that you would want to store
things cuz there are storage places in
here Oh God you go probably gonna crash
the game
oh that was so well amazing that was so
worth it so you can see you fus-ro-dah
yourself a little bit of a space man of
chess there yeah yeah if you were so
inclined you could legitimately steal 11
gold yoke perfect
that's right there's one chicken in here
somewhere somewhere by your feet oh yeah
not him there is you'll get him he's
hiding Wow oh my god amazing
oh the framerate sir he thought he could
hide amongst the stuff he was running
done what have we done
is that it I think I think he may have
crashed have we given it just a few too
many physics something about one chicken
I was my god single solitary chicky I
was so worthwhile
I'll save a thing that's the first time
you've ever had our exploding chickens
of just one chicken just one chicken my
chicken dil broke the game yeah well
thanks for voting for that one I know it
was a quite a basic mod what have you
put things in that room well that's what
I'm thinking you know it it could be
like your little storage room of the
game and say if you if you wanted to be
absorbed in Harry Potter law it's put
all your stuff in there yeah I don't
know if you could maybe drag one of
those out of the place with you to see
if it spawns elsewhere yeah just like
leave them for other people but maybe
anyway yeah so well thanks for voting on
that one for this week there's actually
not going to be a vote this week but
nope before we get to that part anyway
last week we asked you guys to put Kevin
van Nord in your game and you did oh
yeah they've got sent loads of amazing
pictures including as someone else's
character and Kevin Lord tortoise there
was a TARDIS there was a whole story
someone made out of us as well I'm
documented we'll put this up on screen
now you can have a look I documented a
day with Kevin van Nord it was amazing
it's absolutely fantastic yeah I was
worried because I got a couple of
messages from you guys saying that the
the Kevin van lord save wouldn't load
for you so I'm gonna try and have a go
at cleaning
that save and maybe I'll reload it as
well once I I know what was wrong with
it but some of you did succeed and thank
you so much for all of those screenshots
he sent us they are fantastic I said we
also as always have questions yeah first
off this week comes from lurking lion
and they asked random idea cam and sab I
was thinking a full episode of user
voted mods would be cool like you give
us 10 or so different moles to vote on
and we do the highest 5 maybe that
stupid oh well not a little lurking
lion-o you do yourself to service yeah
good idea
so I think we do that the straw poll
that we use for when we do the vote at
the end yeah I mean we only ever put 3
in but I think in straw poll you can
many guys you want so what we can do is
we could put a load of mods in there and
then the the 5 that come out with the
highest percentage just do them we could
do that so that's a brilliant idea
we will do that so Josh I can't actually
say his name I cannot say hey Josh Josh
Wesson there you go yeah you got it you
got it you got it so Josh Wesson also
got in touch ed saying a half-naked man
running across the tundra hitting people
with his giant popsicle when did this
show go into the gutter I'll tell you
when it was about a year ago when cam
and I took over the show over a year ago
well every Bell every year ago and yes
it is now in the gutter but it's a
wonderful glorious gutter full of mods
and fun time yeah and also I'd like to
think that a half naked man that's the
size of you know a city and a half can't
theoretically be in a gutter because
he's simply too big so I say to you sir
impossible logic yeah okay final
question is from pop up pan chat and he
or she says could you please suggest a
way to get skyrim redone frostfall and
hunter pond mods
aside from Nexus mods because I don't
have Nexus available hmm so I believe
this was off the back of a conversation
I had with someone who was trying to
play Skyrim on their tablet
windows 8 surface oh I see of course
so there were some issues I know people
have had trying to get Nexus mod manager
to install on it now you don't need
Nexus mod manager to install Nexus mods
you can download manually every single
every single mod is available for manual
download then it'll it'll come as a as a
RAR file or a 7z file and be able to
unzip that yeah you do that on tablets
okay yeah you should be able to unzip
those even if you can't you can unzip
them on another computer or your aunt's
further network back across and then you
just need to look at where they are
placed so the basic mods so the ESP
files go in your Skyrim data folder
where the games installed and then if
they have meshes and textures and you
know loose files at the air called they
go in the corresponding folders as well
so it is possible possible it's better
it'll be a bit more intent work
intensive but you should be able to do
it yeah it's totally possible to install
mods without a manager there you go so
sir
next week is gonna be a bit special in
fact for the next few weeks things are
gonna be a bit different than we've been
promising it for a while we are being
talking about how we're gonna build the
ultimate PC for making the ultimate
Skyrim and it's finally happening yes
next week yes all the bits have finally
arrived in fact just before we started
recording today the last bit the
motherboard finally arrives shoot it we
are ready to go for that next week so
we're mark Walton is gonna help us build
it that'll probably the first episode
and then after that we will kinda
showcase it running all the best mods
and game Skyrim looking as great as
possible we are gonna make this game
gorgeous yeah that's the plan so that's
gonna be next week and then shortly
after it there's Gamescom so we'll be
preparing some some videos ahead of time
for you guys we don't want to just drop
it
while we're cuz we're gonna be off in
Gamescom we're gonna be there weekend
ruining work and staff and your Skyrim
there no no running games for us for
that week so we'll make sure we've got
plenty of videos prepared for you for
that exactly so no vote this week's air
battles but the next few weeks gonna be
exciting with this PC build and then
after that eventually we'll get back to
normality well normal mod shows so if
you hate change
don't worry it bear with us for a few
weeks but we'll go back
normal with Kevyn Orr's and chickens and
mods and all the good stuff all the
stuff that you come here and subscribe
to exactly yeah in the meantime though
do keep sending us photos of your
characters and Kevin or doing whatever
the hell you want them to do I send them
to me at camp for us Rob or him at Ready
Steady Go you can use the hashtag what
does it say
the hashtag is GES Skyraiders yeah
exactly that it's exactly that wonderful
yeah well thanks for being here serve as
always thanks Peter it's been a good
episode it's been good being friends
with you last night a year and a half's
hope it continues probably we serve
everyone in Scotland votes no so we can
be friends cross your fingers funny
actually have to vote no for us to be
friends that's quite interesting no [ __ ]
right yep okay we'll see you guys next
week for more top 5 Skyrim months of the
week